Bu Mira, okul bahçesi yarın ki 23 Nisan şenliği için süsleniyor.
Bahçenin ucundaki bankta sınıfa yeni gelen bir kız tek başına oturuyor.
Adı Dara.
Ailesi geçen ay Bulgaristan'dan bu mahalleye taşındı.
Mira ona bakıyor ama yanına gitmiyor.
Nedenini kendisi de bilmiyor.
Dünyanın farklı ülkelerinde yaşayan toplumların kendine özgü kültürel özellikleri vardır.
İnsanlar çeşitli nedenlerle bir araya geldiğinde farklı kültürleri tanıma fırsatı bulur.
O bahçede yarın tam olarak bu olacak.
Kültür, bir toplumun tarih oyuncu oluşturduğu maddi ve manevi değerlerin bütünüdür.
Sınıfın panosunda kültürü oluşturan ögeler tek tek asılıydı.
Yemekler, bir kültürün en kolay tanınan yüzüdür.
Kıyafetler, dokundukları iklimi ve geleneği üstünde taşır.
Müzikler ve halk oyunları bir toplumun orta kaafızasıdır.
El sanatları, ustadan çırağa geçerek yüzyıllarca yaşar.
Bayramlar, gelenekler ve görenekler de kültürü oluşturan başlıca ögelerdendir.
Öğle arasında Dara çantasından ince, uzun bir çalgı çıkardı.
Mira o çalgıyı daha önce hiç bu ellerde görmemişti.
Ama ilk sesi duyduğu anda içinden bir şey kıpırdadı.
Aynı ses dedesinin odasında duvarda asılı duran çalgıdan çıkıyordu.
İkisinin de adı Kavaldı.
Kültürler birbirinden farklı özelliklere sahip olabilir.
Ama yemeklerinde, müziklerinde, el sanatlarında ve geleneklerinde benzerlikler de bulunabilir.
Kaval, zurna ve kalaycılık hem Türk hem Bulgar kültüründe görüdür.
Mira o gün uzak sandığı şeyin tanıdık çıktığını gördü.
Ertesi sabah sınıf bir kültür atölyesine dönüştü.
Bir grup suyun üstünde ebru yapıyor, boyalar suda açılıyordu.
Dara kırmızı ve beyaz iklikleri bükerek marten içka örüyordu.
Çocuklar konuşmadan birbirlerinin işine bakıp elinden tuttu.
Farklı kültürlerin tanıtıldığı etkinlikler, insanların birbirini yakından tanımasını sağlar.
Kültürel değerler paylaşıldıkça yeni bilgiler öğrenilir ve iletişim güçlenir.
Böylece insanlar arasında gerçek bir yakınlık kurulur.
Mira dün neden uzakta durduğunu şimdi anlıyordu.
Tanımadan karar vermişti.
O karar ona ait bile değildi.
İnsanları veya toplumları yeterince tanımadan onlar hakkında karar vermek önyargıdır.
Önyargı, bilginin bıraktığı boşluğu tahminle doldurur.
Farklı kültürleri tanımak ve doğru bilgi edinmek önyargıları azaltır.
Önce tanımak, sonra anlamak, en sonunda saygı duymak gelir.
Şenlik günü bahçeye uzun bir sergi masası kuruldu.
Her çocuk kendi kültüründen bir şeyi bu masaya bıraktı.
Hiçbir masa diğerinden yüksek değildi.
Hepsi aynı hizadaydı.
Her toplumun kültürü kendine özgü ve değerlidir.
Farklılıklara saygı, toplumdaki güveni ve dayanışmayı güçlendirir.
Sahnede Kaval Lazurna aynı ezgiyi birlikte çaldı.
Farklılıklar ayrılık nedeni değil, kültürel bir zenginliktir.
Kültürel farklılıklara saygı dostluğu, yardımlaşmayı ve dayanışmayı büyütür.
Önyargılar azalır, toplumsal uyum güçlenir.
İnsanlar huzur içinde birlikte yaşayabilir.
Şenlik bitti, bahçe yeniden boşaldı.
Mira çınarın altındaki o banka bir kez daha baktı.
Bank aynıydı, ışık aynıydı, değişen tek şey vardı.
Farklı kültürleri tanımak kendi kültürümüzü de daha iyi anlamamızı sağlar.
Farklılıklarımız birlikte yaşamamızı zenginleştirir.
Peki sen, çevrene yeni gelen birine nasıl yardımcı olabilirsin?
Cevaplarınızı yorumlara bekliyoruz.
Farklılıklarla kalın, birlikte kalın.